The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
We're now more than a week into Joe
Biden's presidency, there are
certainly things to criticize.
For example, Joe Biden said two thousand dollar
checks are going out right away. If Democrats
win the two Georgia seats, they haven't. Now,
it's not clear exactly what will be in the
covid relief bill. It's not exactly clear when
that is going to be happening. So there's no
question that there are criticisms here. But
if we take a sort of fair and comprehensive
approach to the question, how does Joe Biden's
first week compare to Donald Trump's four years,
I would make the case and I would feel confident
making it that Joe Biden has done more good in
his first eight or nine days in office,
eight days in office, I guess it's been
than Donald Trump did in his entire four
years. A lot of this has to do with the virus,
the coronavirus task force being invigorated,
bringing in actual qualified doctors,
increasing vaccination. We're already up
to one point two million vaccines a day,
figuring out where are these discrepancies in
terms of vaccines, getting vaccines out to people,
number of vaccinating locations going up
dramatically, starting to be very clear about the
possible trajectory trajectory of the virus. That
alone is absolutely huge. But then you look at
pausing the arms sales to Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates, reversing a lot of the
bad decisions made by Donald Trump, including
Joe Biden, getting us back into Paris climate,
back into the O, reversing the trans military
ban, working to promote racial equality through
executive orders after Donald Trump did whatever
he could to get rid of any executive orders
that said, hey, we should really look at
this or we should really look at that,
starting to actually put together some potential
progress on immigration, which has been.
So it's not just that the
discussion has been fraught,
but it's been such a failure under the Trump
administration looking at environmental
regulations that are put back in when they
were once Trump undid via executive order,
but also canceling Keystone XL pipeline.
I mean, I could go on and on and on with the list,
but the amount that he has been able to do
in these first eight or so days really is
more of a counterbalance to Donald Trump's
four years than I could have ever imagined.
And my promise to you when Joe Biden, even
before Joe Biden won and then when he won,
and then when he was confirmed by the
Electoral College and when he was inaugurated,
is that we are going to keep Joe Biden
accountable to the promises that he made.
But when Joe Biden does things that are good,
I'm going to tell you that he did good things.
It doesn't mean he's perfect. It doesn't mean the
Democratic Party is now a bastion and beacon of
progressivism. It simply means that sometimes
presidents do things that are good and they
should be applauded for that. And I think what has
been most fascinating to see about this is that
the country seems to see it. Joe Biden's
first approval rating, 63 percent
higher than Donald Trump's approval rating at
any time during his presidency. Remember that
Donald Trump never even hit 50 percent at any time
during his presidency and presidential approval.
Joe Biden already at 63 percent, 69 percent
approval of Joe Biden's handling of coronavirus in
these early days, 80 81 percent approval of Joe
Biden's federal mask mandate and and national
mask sort of request, I think is the right way to
call it. So we are in a very polarized situation.
Twenty five, twenty eight, 30 percent of the
country is off the deep end in terms of radical,
ignorant politics, as I call
it. So when you consider that
these really are very, very good numbers for
Joe Biden and we are going to continue tracking
his promises and what he does. But
the first seven, eight, nine days,
I am very pleased with and I'm even yesterday we
had a voicemail from a Bernie supporter who said,
I voted Bernie. But I have to tell you, I'm
pleasantly surprised by a lot of what's going
on. And I do believe that in terms of the most
pressing thing, what's happening with vaccinations
is excellent. And I hope that we can soon be
at two, two and a half million vaccines a day.